c'est la première attaque massive qui a
eu lieu ici depuis près d'un mois donc
c'est vrai que les
Ukrainiens finalement sont habitués à
attendre retentir ces sirènes
malheureusement assez fréquemment la
nuit dernière peut après minuit heure de
Kiev on les a entendus ici dans la
capitale
ukrainienne c'est une alerte qui a duré
toute la nuit avec des explosions qui
ont commencé ici dans la capitale à
l'aube vers 5h30 alors c'est vrai comme
je disais les gens sont relativement et
malheureusement habitués à ce cette
menace qui plane au dessus de leur tête
il y a pas forcément beaucoup de gens
qui vont encore s'abriter surtout au
milieu de la nuit dans les parkings
souterrains dans les métros dans des
caves donc il y a beaucoup de gens ce
matin vers 5h30 qui ont été réveillés
simplement par le bruit d'une très forte
explosion ici en centre-ville il a été
suivie par d'autres explosions avec les
autorités qui ont précisé que c'était le
travail le travail de la défense
aérienne ici à Kiev alors il y a des
premiers des premières informations sur
qui font état de deux blessés et le
maire
vitaliclisco a confirmé que des secours
mais d'être en route sur le site alors
de l'explosion est-ce que ça a été une
explosion proposée directement par le
missile ou par un débris domicile suite
au travail de la défense aérienne on ne
sait pas encore reste que pour l'instant
15% des des habitants de la capitale
sont privés d'électricité en raison de
mesures d'urgence de coupure de courant
qui ont été mises en place après ces
frappes d'autres coupures de courant ont
eu lieu notamment à la centrale
nucléaire de zaporigia ce qui montre
également toute la problématique de ces
frappes sur les infrastructures les
impacts à la fois causent à la fois des
dégâts matériels mais elles impactent
aussi sur la durée les habitants quand
elles ne les tuent pas puisque
malheureusement ce sont également des
frappes qui tombent très très
fréquemment sur des immeubles
d'habitation